نبض من الضوء والنور في الرياض خلال
نوفمبر السبب هو مهرجان نور الرياض اللي
يعتبر احتفال سنوي الضوء والفن يعزز من
خلال الابداع ويدعم المواهب وبقدم تجارب
مذهلات نور الرياض كان بدا في الثالث من
نوفمبر واستمر او مستمر لغايه 19 نوفمبر
وكنا احنا تناولنا في تفاعلكم تفاصيل
الاحتفال اللي بيتضمن 500 فعاليه متنوعه
190 عمل فني بمشاركه 100 من الفنانين
المعاصرين من 40 دوله حول العالم ومن
بينهم اربعه وثلاثون في المئه من
السعوديين وغير طبعا هل فعاليات والانشطه
الفنيه والحوارات والتجارب الابداعيه ورش
العمل فالاحتفال هذه السنه ايضا راح ينظم
مزاد فني خيري ياتي ضمن مبادرات مشروع
الرياضه
ويضم اعمال فنيه لاربعه فنانين سعوديين
تعاون مع اربعه جمعيات خيريه كل العوائد
الماليه من المزاد ستستخدم لدعم البرامج
الفنيه للجمعيات الراعيه للمزاد وكل فنان
من الاربعه سيقدم عملين فنيين تعرض في حي
جاكس طوال فتره الاحتفال الممتده التاسعه
والعشرين منه بنت 19 عفوا من نوفمبر كما
ذكرنا بالاضافه لطرحها في مزاد افتراضي
على منصه
بتاريخ 14 و15 نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
معنى من الرياض نوفل منيف مديره احتفال
نور الرياض اهلا بك ست نوف معنا في
تفاعلكم بدايه اعطينا فكره عن مهرجان نور
الرياض عن النشاطات وعن فكرته ورسالته
ايضا
طبعا مرحبا فيكم وشكرا على الاستضافه طبعا
احتفال نور الرياض زي ما ذكرتي اااه انه
هو احتفال سنوي يحتفل بفنون الضوء طبعا
احنا بدانا اوريدي من ثلاثه نوفمبر
وهيستمر يوم 19 نوفمبر تحت عنواننا نحلم
بافاق جديده طبعا همم زي كمان ما قلت ان
عندنا اكثر من 190 عمل فني موزعه على 40
موقع في مدينه الرياض من اكثر من 130 فنان
عملي عالمي ومحلي من 40 دوله تقريبا همم
طبعا عندنا ال ال اكثر من ضمن الفعاليه
عندنا اكثر من 500 من ضمن الاحتفال عندنا
اكثر من 500 فعاليه تتضمن هذه الفعاليات
امم ورش عمل حوارات بين الفنانين عروض
موسيقيه طبعا بعض هذه الفعاليات بتضمن
تذاكر همم وكل هذه التذاكر هتروح لجمعيات
خيريه باذن الله
وفي كمان مزاد علني همم طبعا على اربع
لوحات او عفوا على لوحات يمكن لوحتين لكل
فنان ولا لوحه واحده لاربع فنانين سعوديين
ايضا رايحه سيذهب
الانشطه الخيريه اكيد حطينا اكثر تحديدا
طبعا من ضمن مبادرات الرياضات اللي هو
المزاد الفني الخيري
طبعا بتعاون من اربع فنانين السعوديين
اللي هم دكتور سعد الهويدي دكتور احمد
ماطر راشد الشعشعي ومعاذ العوفي تعاونوا
مع اربع جمعيات خيريه اللي هم جمعيه
النهضه جمعيه الاراده الجمعيه السعوديه
لمرضى الزهايمر وفريق التاهيل الدولي كل
فنان عمل لوحتين بالتعاون مع هذه مع
منسوبين منسوبين الجمعيه واطفال الجمعيه
وطبعا كونوا ثمانيه اعمال فنيه انتل هذه
الاعمال همم معروفه في همم جاكس همم اللي
في الدرعيه همم طبعا وحيط تم طرحها لمزاد
افتراضي يوم 14 و15 نوفمبر طبعا المزاد
الافتراضي اللي هو هيبدا بعد الساعه 12:00
اليوم بالليل باذن الله
وكل هذه المبالغ حتى تروح للجمعيات
الخيريه طيب حتى الان كيف كان اقبال همم
يعني الجماهير على هذا المهرجان هلا يمكن
البعض بعض من فعالياته متخصصه نوعا ما على
الاقل يعني للناس اللي همم مهتمين بالفن
همم يعني ممكن يتابعوه ولكن الناس
العاديين هل هناك ايضا اهتمام او شو
الفعاليات اللي ممكن تكون تجذبهم اكثر من
غيرها
طبعا طبعا همم
بالمشاركه المجتمعيه اللي احنا عاملينها
همم في احتفال الرياضه 2022 اللي هو زي ما
ذكرت اليوم اكثر من 500 فعاليه وهذه
الفعاليات نفسها احنا نبغى همم يعني همم
جريت في اول اودينسز زي ما يقولون نبغى
همم نوصل الفن همم
يعني لكل همم
المجتمع همم في الرياض لزوار مدينه الرياض
للطلاب للطالبات همم عندنا همم يعني سكول
سكولز اللي هي رحلات وجولات للمدارس
الجامعه
نقدر نبغى نحاول نوصل الفن الجميل
طيب والمراه السعوديه كان لها نصيب
الفنانه السعوديه كان لها نصيب ايضا
بالمشاهده همم
المهرجان حاطين عن عن المشاركتها
عندنا طبعا تقريبا اكثر من 15 فنانه
سعوديه مشاركه في احتفال نور الرياض طبعا
احنا عند تقريبا
التي 39 الى 38 فنان سعودي وسعوديه ومنهم
تقريبا اكثر من 15 فنانه طبعا يعني اسامي
ما شاء الله عليهم يعني زي ما يقولون
اسامي جديده في عالم الفن وطبعا الاسامي
طبعا معروفه امم كل هذه الاعمال الفنيه
موجوده في الاحتفال اللي هو حيستمر ليله
19 نوفمبر وكمان موجوده في المعرض المصاحب
اللي هيستمر ان شاء الله لين اربعه فبروري
شكرا جزيلا لك نوفل منيف مديره احتفال نور
الرياض كانت معنا من الرياض ونتمنى لكم كل
التوفيق
ومضه نراها في الافاق
[موسيقى]
تنير الطريق
تنير الحياه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما يدفعون للمضي قدما وما يجعلنا نصل كل
بعيد
[موسيقى]
هي تجمعنا
هي نور الرياض
[موسيقى]